they say you're the best that you can  find anyone you don't ask questions you  don't care what you deliver hundred  thousand dollars to deliver this case  you're 60 hours start now  [Music]  oh you know about this evil self nothing  good this is the forward handguns  I need a Cadillac what they'll have in  the Jimmy she's tough she's smart she's  not afraid of anything for years I've  been ducking flavors  now we haven't because we have something  he wants hardly the traitor when a man  makes those kind of choices you've got  to deal with them consequences don't you  but I guess you go looking for death  you always gotta find that one way or  another  the floor pretending to be something  else that we did go to hell  [Music]  you